grab your french horn and a flaming
sword because we have the latest season
of lucifer and this one
even has a musical episode
[Music]
yes it's been nine months since the
first half of lucifer's season five was
released after the coronavirus shut down
production and with only one more season
ago
lucifer is slowly coming to an end no
hell no in this video we'll be taking a
deep dive into the second half of season
5 its
biggest unanswered questions and what it
could mean for the final season but
before we descend into hell make sure to
like and subscribe
seriously only about eight percent of
you are subscribed and if i don't get
those numbers up my dad won't be proud
of me and i am very proud of the man
you've become
16 episodes have culminated in an epic
battle between the archangel michael and
the devil himself
lucifer while lucifer was cast aside and
banished from heaven
michael became god's right-hand man but
their animosity toward one another stems
from their lack of love from their
father
but instead it's just made me realize
one simple truth
that you will never love us because
you're incapable of love
lucifer resents having been banished to
hell while michael resents that lucifer
is the golden child who got his own
kingdom even though he openly rebelled
against his father
when your twin is the lightbringer turns
out you have no choice but to live in
the shadows
michael has always been the child in his
brother's shadow so when god announces
his retirement it leaves michael
with the perfect opportunity to take
control and become
god himself something lucifer won't
stand for michael doesn't care for human
life he hasn't experienced what it's
like to live amongst humanity
and thus he'd make for a tyrannical god
whereas michael couldn't care less about
humans
lucifer wants to become god for a human
it gets worse i'm doing it
for the love of a human i am trying to
be god
so that i can finally be worthy of her
this dichotomy is shown in the
production design when michael shows up
at lucifer's bar
lux lux by the way meaning light look at
the background here as michael's framed
against hellish red and lucifer heavenly
blue we'll even see how the lighting
bathes lucifer in this blue
glow michael has come with an offer for
lucifer we actually haven't seen michael
since episode 9 when god
banished him from earth to keep the
peace but now since god has left the
universe to be with his wife and hers
it's a total free-for-all while lucifer
has been on earth michael has been
gaining support among the other angels
and assembling pieces of the flaming
sword a weapon which can kill
celestials it's composed of three parts
the blade
hilt and necklace which bind it all
together every piece of the flaming
sword has a power azrael's blade is
death
the hilt divine love and your necklace
is the strength that binds them together
michael tells lucifer that he has all
the parts but
that's a lie in episode 15 we learned
that a menadile's necklace one of the
three parts of the flaming sword which
he left on the grave of caleb mayfield
who you may remember from season 4
is in the possession of a black market
dealer named tj
ross amanda deal put this necklace on
caleb's body before
he was buried but lucifer suggests that
a technician at the coroner's office
must have taken it before caleb's body
was buried this tech is jonathan
donnelly a man running a scam where he'd
steal loved ones personal items and sell
them back to their families for profit
but
jonathan is killed and the item falls
into the hands of tj
those in possession of it have
superhuman strength which is why when
lucifer and chloe confront him
he's able to kick lucifer halfway across
the room but back to michael's offer he
doesn't want there to be
any unnecessary bloodshed and is willing
to give lucifer his old job as
ruler of hell but this time he can rule
alongside chloe making her queen of hell
the only problem is only someone's guilt
can take them to hell
michael says chloe is damned to hell
because of the guilt she feels for the
death of dan
espinoza after all it was the case she
was working on that got him killed but
more on this guilt thing in a bit
speaking of dan mazzaquin amenadil and
linda are packing up things after his
tragic death in the penultimate episode
he was killed by a group of french
mercenaries hired by michael to locate
the missing piece of the flaming sword
this death hits maze especially hard and
no wonder considering her character arc
this season mazes had to struggle with
whether or not she'll be able to have a
soul
in fact she makes a deal with michael to
get her an audience with god the only
person that can grant her such a thing
maize is a demon and demons don't have
souls although god doesn't end up giving
her one he does give her a glimmer of
hope but a demon can't grow a soul
can't she maize then tells linda a few
episodes later that it feels like a soul
is growing inside her like a baby
but it isn't until the arrival of eve
that may sees the downside of having a
soul
turns out having a soul mate that can
die
it's torture having a soul means having
to endure the pain of losing those we
love
something maize experiences when she
almost loses eve
she ends up breaking up with eve because
of this her own personal hell would be
to relive losing her
every day which is why she makes a deal
with lucifer to become the ruler of hell
should he become
god if she rules hell she escapes that
torment but what maze fails to realize
is that you can't have love and joy
without a bit of pain
sometimes when you care about people
you have to go through pain and loss
but that's the price of joy i think
linda puts it best here saying
never loving anyone is far worse
than loss lucifer tells chloe he needs
to be god for dan's sake he sees
this system as unjust how can a good man
like dan spend
eternity in hell your system is not only
broken it's unjust
remember that this season was written
during the events of black lives matter
and the 2020 presidential election which
may be why plot points like voting
between two people you really couldn't
care for winning and breaking down
unjust systems have wedged their way
into the story
remyel arrives with a cryptic message
before succumbing to her wounds that
were given to her by michael
because her wound isn't burned chloe
surmises that michael must not have all
the parts of the sword
so if they can get their hands on the
final part before michael does they
might stand a chance at stopping him
rimeo holds a clue a
feather which they give to ella for
analysis ella has gone on her own
journey this season ever since she found
out her boyfriend was a serial killer
she's
buried herself in work and refuses to
see anyone else
even dan's hunky friend carol corbett
the two meet briefly at dan's funeral so
expect him to make more of an appearance
in season six the emu feather covered in
yeast
ends up leading them to an abandoned
beer factory
lucifer ends up disguising himself as
michael in order to retrieve the
necklace from tj but is ultimately
thwarted when the real michael arrives
unlike lucifer michael doesn't spare
tj's life which really points at one of
the main differences between these two
lucifer has reverence for humanity while
michael does not
lucifer and chloe are able to escape but
not without leaving michael with
all the pieces of the flaming sword and
with the vote for a new god tomorrow
it's not looking good for them
mei's catfishes eve as steve which is
kind of funny because steve is just eve
with an st
she's come to the realization that the
joy and love she has for eve
far outweighs the pain if she loses her
shoehorned in this episode is the idea
of falling and getting back up falling
is how humans learn is how i learned
linda remarks how charlie falls more
than some of the other children but
that's just part of growing up as amena
deal echoes you have to risk falling if
you want to fly chloe and lucifer will
both fall this episode
but come back stronger than they were
before the final battle ironically takes
place at the la memorial coliseum a
stadium commissioned in 1921 to honor
the veterans of world war one
a hundred years later an entirely new
battle will wage here lucifer much like
jon snow
refuses to bend the knee instead asking
for a vote
in a speech he tells them that michael
is using fear to sway the other angels
to his side a tactic some other
politicians have used they're bringing
drugs
they're bringing crime they're rapists
only zadkiel the angel of righteousness
and raziel come to lucifer's side
zadkil has seen how lucifer is wanting
to be god out of love well
raziel was disheartened to find out
michael killed remyel in his quest for
power
the other notable angel here is gabriel
it was her who brought back asriel's
blade to michael after it was
tossed into the goddess's universe way
back in season 2. with the vote finished
michael proclaims that he is god but
nothing happens leaving them to believe
the vote has to be unanimous and if it
has to be unanimous that means the
opposing votes
must be killed and of course when your
life is on the line you burst into can't
touch this
no no this is all a ploy to buy some
time as maze and eve have harnessed
their own army of the dead from a group
of convicts we saw a barrel over a cliff
at the beginning of the final episode
you may even notice that maze controls
the dead by speaking lilim the language
of demons the name deriving from lilith
adam's first wife and mazzakeen's mother
she's important but we'll get to her in
a bit michael laughs at lucifer's
pitiful attempt at an army especially
chloe's gun which won't work on them
angels are invulnerable that is until he
finds out they have melted down maze's
demon blade into bullets which can kill
them turns out melting down one demon
blade makes a lot of bullets
to avoid further bloodshed michael and
lucifer fight one-on-one to the death to
decide who becomes god
a bit of an unfair fight since michael
has the flame sword but lucifer gets a
bit of a helping hand with a staff made
from the tree of life
and when it looks like michael might
finally persevere chloe rips out the
necklace but ultimately is killed by
michael lucifer runs to her side and in
her final words chloe reveals she does
not have any guilt
thus sending her to heaven where she
will never be able to see lucifer again
lucifer will burst into flames if he
ever sets foot there but lucifer doesn't
care he's willing to risk
everything for the person he loves and
so he sets off for heaven and when he
arrives there he is magically still
alive that's because he has lilith's
ring of immortality in the first half of
the season we saw how lilith not wanting
to be immortal anymore transferred her
immortality into the ring
and gave it to lucifer the power of
heaven however is too much
and it only has enough juice to take one
person back so lucifer
sacrifices himself takes off the ring
and gives it to chloe so she can be
resurrected back on earth fun fact the
actor who plays chloe's dad is actually
married to the actress who plays mazakin
he also refers to chloe as my little
monkey a title of a season 2 episode
where chloe tries to track down her
father's killer but there are huge
implications with lucifer's discovery
that lee garner
is also in heaven lee has been a
recurring character since season 2
with it being a reoccurring joke that he
always appears in the beginning of the
show's season premieres
which is exactly what happened at the
beginning of season 5 for example
you want to join us hail to the yeah
but lee is supposed to be in hell how is
it that he's in heaven no soul has ever
made it from hell
to heaven lee tells him that he's not
exactly sure but he faced his family and
his guilt and
boom heaven this gives us hope for dan
in season six
if lee could face his guilt why not dan
and if lucifer becomes god and may's the
ruler of hell i doubt this is the last
we'll see of dan
espinoza lucifer's sacrifice also comes
on the heels of him saying that thing
we've waited five full seasons for
remember that lucifer can't tell a lie
so when he tells chloe he loves her he
really means it and that's part of
lucifer's character arc he believed that
he was like his father
incapable of love like him i
i am incapable of love but his feelings
for chloe and his sacrifice prove
otherwise he is not like his father and
perhaps this points to how different of
a god he will be
when chloe reawakens on earth she
catches michael by surprise as she's
holding on to the necklace giving her
super strength she's able to pick up
asriel's blade the only thing that can
kill a celestial but before she's about
to kill michael
lucifer appears lucifer is now god
pretty much confirmed by him saying
oh my me instead of oh my god but as
chloe asks
lucifer how you i don't know
lucifer himself isn't sure this will
undoubtedly be addressed next season but
if i were to hazard a guess it has to do
with love and sacrifice
sacrifice has been a big component of
season five in fact many of the episodes
this season deal with family members
sacrificing themselves to save those
they love for example linda pleads
guilty to murder in episode 13 to
protect her daughter and peter in
episode 9 pleads guilty to murder to
protect his family you were willing to
sacrifice yourself for your own children
of course that's what fatherhood is
lucifer had to prove his love for
humanity
through sacrifice that was the key
factor in deciding who becomes god
and this was all part of god's plan
remember he's omniscient and knew of
this outcome in advance lucifer has now
become the father of humanity
as god and as god lucifer tells chloe
not to kill michael he will be a
different type of god one who is willing
to give
second chances he even chops off
michael's wings just like his were
chopped off after his failed rebellion
the other angels including michael bend
the knee to him as their new deity
above him you can see the sun and flames
his last name is morningstar after all
but where does this leave us for season
six
this episode was originally supposed to
be the series finale but was changed
after the show was picked up for a
surprise
sixth and final season so it's entirely
possible the creators always imagined
the ending of lucifer with him as god
now you might think where can we go from
here and there are a couple of clues
and loose threads first we have dan in
hell actor kevin alejandro who plays dan
is directing some of the episodes next
season and one of them is titled goodbye
lucifer
these episode titles have already been
revealed which give us some clues
with titles like goodbye lucifer and
partners till the end i can't help but
think that lucifer's reign as god which
will undoubtedly be the focus of season
6
will come to an end if i were to guess
lucifer will give up his title to amend
a deal so he can live as a mortal with
chloe if lucifer is god it also begs the
question
who will be the villain who can possibly
take on god well it's possible that
there may not be a villain like michael
but that the season will focus on
lucifer balancing his new life as god
chloe struggled with how lucifer will
deal with this balancing act of being
god
and a partner lucifer also saw how the
job affected his father's relationships
with his family i also don't think
lucifer will fully have all his godlike
powers at least not yet this will likely
be something he has to learn over time
rather than him inheriting them at the
snap of a finger
one of the episodes is titled save the
devil save the world which hints at
something much larger coming into play
and with this series dabbling in
alternate universes
it will be interesting to see how the
writers navigate the problem of an
antagonist for a seemingly
unkillable character but what did you
think of lucifer's season 5 and what are
your theories for this sixth and final
season
i want to hear them in the comments
below thanks for watching and make sure
to like and subscribe it really helps
the channel out and for more bad takes
you can always follow me on twitter and
instagram
at thingstoryt until next time remember
daddy loves you very much